2015 was the year of wonderful RPGs like
fallout 4 and The Witcher 3 and rolling
matches of rocket League and tense
adventures in Metal Gear Solid 5 that
said there were some real crap fests and
just I'm gonna talk about those games
wander the exploration based MMO sounded
as fascinating as it did difficult to
pull off while it sparked interest early
by subverting typical MMO mechanics like
not including combat or leveling it
turned out that taking the path less
traveled it wasn't such a good thing
unfortunately the issues don't begin and
end with the fact that there really
isn't anything to do in wonder or any
real motivation to explore wonder was
riddled with bugs and glitches on
release and every interesting feature
seemed to be met with a new bevy of
problems for example the game lets you
adopt different forms and in your tree
form you can barely see the road in
front of you thanks to the giant
character model textures may or may not
load the touchpad may or may not respond
to the speech clips you draw on it and
you may or may not decide to put down
this unique MMO that doesn't quite hit
the mark that said the music is
fantastic so at least there's that last
murder simulator hatred already felt
pretty bloody tasteless in today's
social climate although it turned out it
wasn't just offensive
it was offensively terrible when the
trailer landed it was certainly
controversial but once hatred launched
it appeared there wasn't even a decent
game buried under the outcry inducing
civilian killing concept basically you
kill mostly innocent sometimes armed
people in isometric levels drive
vehicles that feel like they do not want
to be driven and pretty much do that and
only that stage after stage while the
antagonistic protagonist gets more and
more petulant in his monologues that
Berman's society never has gun rampage
in combat belts at this boring
the fact that one of the only nice
things that I review at Peter Brown had
to say about Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5
was that skating is occasionally fun
really sums up my reasons for including
it in this video
expectations were pretty high for this
one given earlier pro skater games have
proved to be Fant sic and provided the
soundtrack to a lot of people's teenage
years unfortunately a pro skater fives
only real resemblance to the earlier
games is that the graphics make it look
like it came out 15 years ago the fact
that the developer decided to change the
art style last minute probably didn't
help although there are a few moments
where skating feels creative and fun the
new slam mechanic messes with the
series's tried-and-true gameplay and the
game's eight maps are tiny and
uninspired expect your best skate moves
to include skating into sacks of pizza
boxes and clipping through scenery Afro
Samurai 2 revenge of kuma was supposed
to have to follow-up volumes suffice it
to say it no longer will whether you're
offended by the objectification of women
terrible voice acting or just awful
gameplay chances are you'll find
something to load in revenge of kuma the
first Afro Samurai in 2009 was actually
pretty well received
unfortunately the follow-up is
underpinned by a weird indulgent script
and sloppy combat mechanics that are
mainly comprised of button mashing and
poorly optimized q TAS just last month
the game was pulled from sale and the
developer versus evil called it a
failure saying they wouldn't be making
any more volumes and finally our worst
game of the year has to go to the only
one out of 10 that we awarded this year
ravenscry back in 1987 sid meier's
pirates made being a pirate super
freakin cool and now in 2015
ravenscry has made it a massive damn
drag
if you make it past the game breaking
bugs you'll be treated to the jewel joys
of misogynistic and homophobic dialogue
as well as numerous hard crashes birth
ship and ground combat feel like a
really busted Assassin's Creed alpha
punctuated with or collision detection
the game hovers between wildly broken
and simply tedious thanks to a cliche
storyline pointless and uninteresting
characters on top of racist and
tone-deaf writing the game has now been
re-released as Vendetta curse of
ravenscry in a year that featured hatred
it took a real special snowflake to out
defend that game but here we are
well done Ravens cry let me know down in
the comments which game was your worst
of the year or which games he was simply
disappointed by I will catch you again
next week for our last episode of the
year